Dietmar Arnold – seit rund 20 Jahren
erforscht er Berlins Untergrund
und hat 1997 den Verein
„Berliner Unterwelten“ mitgegründet.
Sein Arbeitsplatz hat keine Fenster
und liegt rund acht Meter unter Berlin.
Zehntausende Kubikmeter Schutt haben er
und sein Team hier über Jahre rausgetragen
und damit
unterirdische Baudenkmäler freigelegt,
zum Beispiel Brauereikeller und Fluchttunnel.
Die Idee dazu kam Dietmar Arnold in Paris.
Als ich 1988 dann
Stadt- und Regionalplanung studiert habe,
gab’s ’n Austausch mit Pariser Stadtplanern,
und ich bin da in eine Gruppe von Kataphilen
geraten, die also sozusagen die Katakomben
unter Paris erkundet haben.
Es gab da drei rivalisierende Gruppen
und bei der einen ...
ich hab‘ denen dann geholfen,
da unten zu vermessen und weiß ich was.
Und bin dann so zwei Tage mit denen mal
unterwegs [gewesen],
und da hab‘ ich mich infiziert.
Und dann kam ich zurück nach Berlin
und dachte, ich muss mal gucken,
was ist eigentlich unter dem Boden
der eigenen Stadt los.
Dieser neu gebaute Zugang
führt zu einem der letzten Fluchttunnel,
mit denen Menschen
aus der einst geteilten Stadt
von Ost nach West gelangen sollten.
17 DDR-Bürgern sollte er den Weg
in die Freiheit ermöglichen.
Es fehlten nur noch zehn Meter,
aber dann flog der Plan auf.
Einer der Tunnelgräber
war der Westberliner Klaus Köppen.
Er wollte so seine schwangere Frau zu sich in
den freien Westteil der Stadt holen.
Ja, hier gucken wir jetzt in den
Originaltunnel aus dem Jahre 1970/71 rein.
Das ist der einzige Tunnel, den man
tatsächlich jetzt im Original sehen kann
aus der Zeit der Berliner Mauer.
Auch viele Hilfsmittel und Werkzeuge
der Tunnelbauer sind im Original zu sehen.
Oberirdisch markieren Platten
den Verlauf des Tunnels von West nach Ost.
Die Teilung der Stadt
hat Dietmar Arnolds Leben geprägt.
Es gab Freunde im Osten der Stadt,
die ihn nie besuchen konnten.
1964 wird er im Westteil geboren.
Zum Studium zieht er in die Nähe der Grenze
an der Bernauer Straße.
Wenn ich jetzt aus Westdeutschland
Besuch bekommen habe –
wie Freunde, Bekannte, Verwandte auch, –
dann bin ich nie
zum Brandenburger Tor gefahren.
Das war so bei uns eigentlich auch verpönt.
Wenn, dann immer hier
an die Bernauer Straße.
Es gab quasi an jeder Straßenkreuzung ...
gab’s so Holzpodeste auf der Westseite,
die waren so hoch gebaut,
dass man von dort aus
richtig über die Mauer ganz weit nach
Ost-Berlin reingucken konnte.
Ganz in der Nähe liegt seine Stammkneipe,
der „Biermichel“.
Seit seiner Jugend spielt er Akkordeon –
heute am liebsten
Lieder aus den 1920er Jahren.
Ich bin ja ’n echter Berliner, um es mal so
auszudrücken, und ich freue mich einfach,
dass also auch bei ... auch doch bei den
jüngeren Leuten sogar noch ’n Interesse an
diesen Liedern da ist,
und die sind ja zum Teil richtig brandaktuell,
wenn man sich die Texte
der 20er Jahre da anguckt.
Und es können also hier auch einige
mitsingen, und ich find’ also ...
ich kämpfe gerne dafür – deswegen sing ich
das auch, dass so was nie ausstirbt.
Genau wie die Berliner Eckkneipe,
die darf auch nie aussterben.
Und für die Freilegung von Baudenkmälern
unter den Straßen von Berlin
will der 54-Jährige auch so lange kämpfen,
wie er kann.
Dieser Brunnen von 1863
ist eine der letzten Entdeckungen.
Er gehörte zu einer Brauerei
und führt noch heute Wasser.
Für mich ist Berlin die Stadt
der Zeitgeschichte des 20. Jahrhunderts
von der Kaiserzeit
über die Weimarer Republik
über die NS-Zeit über die Nachkriegszeit
und die deutsche Teilung
und dann die Wiedervereinigung.
Wir haben hier alles wirklich erlebt. Man kann
hier also Geschichte wirklich toll vermitteln.
Eben nicht nur über,
sondern auch unter der Erde.
Das beweist Dietmar Arnold
mit seinem Verein „Berliner Unterwelten".
Tschüss.